Jessica Biel definitely Justin's mirror
as the curly-haired 90s version of
Timberlake remember don't show that to
anybody
sorry but posing with this insane
entourage was kind of the perfect way
for just to troll her man
he's the microphone a source says they
were very affectionate all night maybe
cuz just told us they'd be a part frock
Tober 31st this may be a disappointing
year for us JT was the mic drop for
these faux Spice Girls at Randy Gerber
star-studded cos amigos party in LA
across town Kylie Jenner made sure
little stormy twinned with mom's Met
Gala look while Gabrielle Union and
daughter Kavita were ready to bring it
on meanwhile Kerry Washington asked fans
to predict what she would be this is an
ET exclusive Kerry Washington is about
to talk about her Halloween costume well
the voting did come in for how to get
away with murder but I have to say that
I am gonna be uma from defendants yes
yeah I have a four and a half year old
knows everything he goes I love Will
Smith is Jeannie dad I'm gonna be the
Will Smith version of Jeannie you're
gonna be the rug dad we'll always we
talked at an event promoting Americans
son the real-life mom plays a parent of
a missing teen to be able to kind of
explore how vulnerable parenthood makes
you is a privilege for me at this point
in my career
[Music]